hi there steve coffin here
i have a proposal
uh any of you out there who are um
working on your english or even on
another language
uh how would you like to come to
vancouver
now you have to pay your own way we're
not paying for it but
spend three months with our link team at
our link headquarters in west vancouver
uh spend part of the day
working on english or some other
language at link or in other activities
and then spend the rest of time
interacting in english with our team
here at link headquarters
and of course spend the rest of time
living in vancouver in english
uh the idea came up and uh by the way
there'll be a link in the description to
more details and how this is going to
function
but the idea is this that i see all the
people who come to vancouver who go to
schools who sit in the classroom three
hours a day five hours a day
uh with other learners
and i've always thought you know if i
went somewhere
to when i went to prague if i were to go
to warsaw or somewhere to make a
breakthrough in my language i would
rather
than going to school i would work with
link i would read i would listen
i would buy the newspaper i would sit in
a cafe i would watch television and i
would love to have an opportunity to
interact regularly
in a meaningful way
with the local native speakers so we
thought why not do that at link for a
three month period
film the whole process
have interviews with people when they
begin and at the end of three months and
so forth
and see how much of a breakthrough
people can make in their level of
english i say other languages because if
there is someone
who's learning another language and very
much much wants to come
we'll make sure that there is at least
one participant who speaks the language
that that person is learning that you
are learning
and so then you could also participate
so that's just a brief introduction to
the idea
if you want more details
please have a look at the at the link
that's in the description
and then let us know if you are
interested and maybe i'll see some of
you
uh in vancouver this summer
bye for now